let me start by reminding everyone about
our step-by-step action plan to defeat
coronavirus at every step of this
process we have followed the latest
scientific and medical advice our goal
is to slow the spread of the virus and
protect the ability of the NHS to cope
we've taken unprecedented action to
increase NHS capacity with more beds
more staff and more equipment on the
frontline and we've told people to stay
at home so that we can protect lives and
protect the NHS today's daily figures
show that two hundred and thirty two
thousand seven hundred and eight people
in the UK have now been tested for
coronavirus sixty thousand seven hundred
and thirty-four people have tested
positive an increase of five thousand
four hundred and ninety two cases since
yesterday nineteen thousand four hundred
and thirty eight people have been
admitted to hospital and sadly of those
in hospital seven thousand and ninety
seven have now died an increase of nine
hundred and thirty-eight fatalities
since yesterday our thoughts are with
the family and friends of those who have
passed away people I'm sure will also
want an update on the Prime Minister's
health he is receiving excellent care
from the NHS team as in Thomas's the
latest from the hospital is that the
Prime Minister remains in intensive care
where his condition is improving I can
also tell you that he has been sitting
up in bed and engaging positively with
the clinical team the Prime Minister is
not only my colleague and my boss but
also my friend and my thoughts are with
him and his family the news about the PM
reminds us how indiscriminate this
disease is nearly everyone will know
someone who's been affected friends
family neighbors colleagues this is a
terrible virus that respects no
boundaries of status or geography or
vocation but we are not facing it alone
we are all take
part in a collective national effort to
protect the vulnerable and each other to
secure our public services and to save
lives this endeavor is underpinned by an
important simple idea that we depend on
each other when you need it when you
fall on hard times we will all as one
society be there for you to take care of
you until you are once again ready to
take care of yourself and others this
idea has been central to all of our
efforts to support people and businesses
during this crisis we promise to do
whatever it takes and I am striving
every day to keep that promise but when
I say we all depend on each other I
don't just mean the relationship between
individuals businesses and the state one
of our greatest strengths as a country
is our civil society the local charities
who provide so much compassion care and
community to the most vulnerable in our
country you have not been forgotten
British people businesses and
foundations are already doing their part
to support our charity sector and today
we in government will do our part as we
build on our plan for the economy with a
plan to support our social fabric there
are nearly a hundred and seventy
thousand Charities in this country and
the truth is we will not be able to
match every pound of funding that they
would have received this year charities
can already use many of our existing
schemes to support people and to protect
their staff all charities are eligible
for the job retention scheme and in line
with medical advice and just like any
other employer the right answer for many
charities will be to furlough their
employees but some charities are on the
frontline of fighting the coronavirus
and others provide critical
services and support to vulnerable
people and communities for them shutting
up shop at this moment would be to
contravene their very purpose their
entire reason to exist those charities
have never been more needed than they
are now and they've never faced such a
sudden fall in their funding so today
I'm announcing 750 million pounds of
funding for the charity sector 370
million pounds of that funding will
support small local charities working
with vulnerable people we all know who
they are those small charities in our
villages our market towns in pockets of
our cities the unsung heroes looking
after the vulnerable and holding
together our social fabric in England
this support will be provided through
organizations like the National Lottery
community's fund and we will allocate
sixty million pounds of this funding
through the Barnett formula to Scotland
Wales and Northern Ireland the UK
government will also provide three
hundred and sixty million pounds
directly to charities providing
essential services and supporting
vulnerable people as we battle the
coronavirus up to two hundred million
pounds of those grants will support
hospices with the rest going to
organisations like sin Johns Ambulance
and the Citizens Advice bureaux as well
as charity supporting vulnerable
children victims of domestic abuse or
disabled people and last night the BBC
announced their big night in charity
appeal on April the 23rd and today I can
confirm that the government will match
pound for pound whatever the public
decides to donate starting with at least
20 million pounds to the national
emergencies trust appeal two short weeks
ago I spoke of the need for kindness
decency and the sort of neighborliness
that is at the heart of these charitable
and community efforts the normally
invisible connections between us have in
some weeks become more apparent for most
of us we spend our lives oblivious to
these connections these bonds and how
our behaviors however small can have a
dramatic effect on others but these
bonds are not invisible for our local
charities for the volunteer keeping
victims of domestic violence safe for
the outreach worker helping a rough
sleeper find a bed or for the support
worker manning the phones to help stave
off the heart-wrenching loneliness so
many of our elderly relatives and
friends will be experiencing right now
these connections might be hard to see
but they are there and they are
strengthened by our compassion for
others charities embody this like no
other organization and their lesson is
that the simplest acts have the
potential to change lives at this Hut
time when many are hurting and tired and
confined we need the gentleness of
charities in our lives it gives us hope
it makes us stronger and it reminds us
we depend on each other